tengo curiosidad de que nos va a dar la
suma de un número racional racional ok
si los sumamos si los sumamos con un
número irracional vamos a sumarlo con un
número y ración
que vamos a obtener de la suma de estos
dos y bueno como todavía no sabemos el
resultado que te parece si suponemos que
la suma de estos dos nos da nos da un
número racional vamos a ver dónde
llegamos si pensamos que nos da un
número raro
ok si esto fuera cierto entonces lo
podremos ver de la siguiente manera que
un número racional y voy a suponer que
este número se llama a / b a / b
ok si a a / b le sumó un número
irracional y como los números racionales
son muy largos
le voy a poner mejor el nombre de x x va
a ser mi número irracional mi número
irracional le voy a poner lo voy a
bautizar con el nombre de x a / b más x
esto quiero que me dé un número racional
ya este número racional
le voy a poner el nombre de m / m m / n
ok si esto fuera cierto entonces de
equipo despejar a mi número y racional y
si me ocurre a despejarlo para que lo
veas de la siguiente manera x es
exactamente lo mismo que m / n que m / m
m / n ya esto le voy a quitar le voy a
quitar este de aquí es decir
esencialmente lo que estoy haciendo es
restar a entre vez de ambos lados de
esta igualdad entonces a esto le voy a
quitar a sobre ve ahora date cuenta que
esta operación si la podemos realizar
esto es exactamente lo mismo que y voy a
encontrar un denominador común
denominador común y voy a decir que es
devolver n por be ok y bueno como puedo
expresar a m / n con este denominador de
n por bent bueno realmente lo que
tenemos que hacer es multiplicar tanto
arriba como abajo por b
entonces voy a multiplicar arriba por
ver abajo por ver de tal manera que ya
tengo el mismo denominador el
denominador común y arriba me quedo en x
20 entonces aquí voy a poner a déjame
cambiar de color
m/m por b por be ok ya esto le quiero
quitar le quiero quitar y bueno ahora
como podemos representar a entre b con
un mismo denominador con nuestro
denominador común bueno para esto
lo que nos hace falta es la n iv
qué voy a hacer es multiplicar tanto
arriba como abajo por n a por mb por n
de tal manera que tengo b x en el que es
lo mismo que 9 y arriba me queda am que
multiplica a en y lo voy a poner con
este color que multiplica a en ok es
decir que x es igual a mb menos apuren
entre n b ahora quiero que te des cuenta
lo siguiente en la parte de abajo
tengo la multiplicación de un número
entero por un número entero como estos
dos son unos racionales tanto a como b
como m como n son enteros y la
multiplicación de un entero por un
entero me da un número entero
pero de lujo ahora vamos a fijarnos la
parte de arriba en la parte de arriba
tengo aquí la multiplicación de dos
números enteros lo cual por cierto es un
número entero entero ya esto le voy a
quitar la multiplicación de dos números
enteros lo cual por cierto es un número
entero ok y qué pasa si yo tengo a un
entero y le quitó un número entero pues
me va a dar un número entero estoy
diciendo que estos dos estos dos la
resta de estos dos me va a dar un número
entero entero es decir esencialmente me
estoy tomando la división de un número
entero entre un número entero vamos a
ponerlo aquí esto lo mismo que un entero
entero ok
mb menos a n es un número entero aunque
sea en un número entero ok ya esto lo
estoy dividiendo entre n por lo cual
también es un número entero
pero ahora si esto pasa esto quiere
decir que este número de aquí un entero
entre un entero es un número racional es
de aquí es un número racional que por
cierto era el valor de x era el valor de
x entonces x debería de ser un número
racional déjame ponerlo con este color x
debería ser d
racional
porque obtuvimos un número racional x
debería de ser racional pero nosotros
habíamos dicho que x es racional y aquí
está la contradicción si nosotros
suponemos que un racional + un
irracional nos da un número racional
entonces llegamos a una contradicción
una contradicción esto no puede ser
cierto y esto no puede ser cierto porque
x no puede ser racional e irracional
al mismo tiempo x por una parte me dice
que debe de ser irracional y por otra
parte me dice que debe ser racional y
esto no puede ser cierto por lo tanto
esta expresión total no puede ser cierta
esto no puede ser cierto que la suma de
un racional + un irracional medio
racional porque llegamos a una
contradicción es decir que nosotros
queremos escribir bien la suma con
racional + un irracional nos debe de dar
un número irracional forzosamente déjame
borrar la pantalla para poner nuestra
conclusión vamos a quitar esto de aquí y
vamos a poner a una nueva pantalla y
vamos a poner justo aquí la conclusión a
la que llegamos
nosotros tenemos un racional un racional
ya éste le sumamos le sumamos un número
irracional déjame ponerlo con este color
le sumamos un número y racional y
racional ya sabemos a qué llegamos la
suma de un racional con un irracional
nos da un número irracional nos da un
número irracional que es justo la
conclusión de este vídeo esto es muy
importante que lo tengas en cuenta hasta
la próxima